[Music]
flags nationwide were lowered to
half-mast as here in Rome as
overburdened hospitals and health care
workers struggled to cope Italy remains
the epicenter of the pandemic in Europe
with almost one hundred and two thousand
people infected a nationwide lockdown
has been in place for weeks and the
government has warned that it could go
on for much longer and joining me now
from Rome is correspondent Sima Gupta so
you know it's striking really to see
this shift in Italy since the outbreak
began I mean we we had videos a few
weeks ago of residents on balconies
singing and now silence you're
absolutely right sir I mean it's from
singing to silence singing for
solidarity and silence really to
remember all the victims the more than
11,500 victims people who have died with
kovat 19 as well as to honor the health
care workers that are fighting this
infection this infectious disease it's
important to remember of that more than
11,500 victims you did you do have at
least 61 doctors that have lost their
lives to Kovac 19 but the flags were
flying at half-mast all throughout Italy
as well as at the Vatican and a real a
somber reality of that staggering figure
for many people to remember that said
that the authorities are trying to
stress the fact that the number of new
infections does appear to be stabilizing
and some have projected that perhaps the
peak of infections could arrived within
the next seven to ten days and in the
meantime we know that residents have
been under strict lockdown for weeks now
it was supposed to end on Friday but now
it's been extended until at least April
12th that's Easter Sunday how are people
coping with such a long lockdown like
this you know you're right it's day 22
now off this lockdown in for a lot of
families of course there's a massive
psychological stress just being cooped
up at home and having to juggle work
life as well as family life and school
life for their children that's for those
who are lucky enough to have jobs and
fortunately there are those that are
really struggling literally to make ends
meet because you either are unemployed
or for instance particularly in the
south of the country which is poorer and
has a higher unemployment rate you have
people who often do clandestine work or
work in the black as they say even that
work has run out and so they are hat
struggling just to buy food to feed
their families and that's why the
government has set aside four hundred
million euros to be distributed among
all the Town Council's and that they
will use to set up food vouchers so that
people can feed themselves and their
families and there will be an additional
4.3 billion euros of help on its way
that said though there is concern about
the economic impact all of this is
having here in Italy and there's some
concern that the European countries up
north should be doing more to help build
Italy and perhaps create a more
solidarity in terms of helping Italy
deal with its debt crisis as well and so
a lot of Mayors as well as regional
officials have written a letter to
Germany asking for a greater
coordination as one is done after World
War two all kinds of measures on the
table including a so-called corona bond
Seema Gupta joining us with the view
from Rome today thank you
really reckoned to have one of the best
health care systems in Europe but as
with other countries the number of
confirmed Corin virus cases keeps
relentlessly rising there are now more
than 67,000 confirmed cases in the
country the German government has warned
that the health care system faces its
biggest challenge in 75 years and
already cracks are starting to show the
German city of Wolfsburg has been badly
affected by the corona virus at least 17
people recently died in a care home and
now this hospital has been forced to
stop receiving new patients after
various employees tested positive this
case is an example of how the crisis in
this country which is one of the most
affected in Europe is testing the limits
of its health care system it is often
considered one of the most
Vance in the world but the pandemic is
also revealing its weaknesses there are
reports of staff and equipment shortages
of unnecessary bureaucracy of lacking
digitalization and also of a frequent
need to improvise the government and in
particular the Health Minister are aware
of the challenges ahead
absolutely adrift doctors and nurses are
probably preparing for the biggest
challenge in 75 years we already have
many infected people in Germany and we
also mourn many deaths this is still the
calm before the storm
for them strong Germany has
comparatively few coronavirus deaths
which is partly to do with the high
number of tests in the country but this
is not enough to weather the storm and
that's why a package of measures has
been passed to help hospitals
financially reduce bureaucracy and
expedite reaction times and Berlin is
planning to build a new hospital which
could house between 500 and 1,000
patients the government has asked for
doctors to be brought out of retirement
and for hospitals to suspend any non
urgent operations in order to free up
intensive care beds Germany already has
more beds than many countries in Europe
and that's why it has been able to bring
in 50 coronavirus patients from France
and from Italy Germany sees this as
European solidarity in times of crisis
but as the infection rate here continues
to be too high for authorities to lift
restrictions it remains a big question
whether Germany's own health system will
be able to pass the test and for more
I'm joined now by Andrew Oman a member
of the Parliament for the German
opposition party the Free Democrats he's
also a professor of infect ology thank
you so much for joining us here on DW
news are you anticipating a sharp
increase in coronavirus deaths in the
next weeks in the next months I'm afraid
so that the death rates will further
increase here in Germany as well we were
so lucky as a country if you look at the
amount of infected patients and look at
the numbers of death we're still less
than 1% this is a very low count so far
the global community if you compare us
however those numbers will still
increase even if we stay with 1% those
numbers of people who were sick come on
Kovac 19 will be increasing you
mentioned that the numbers here do tend
to at least on the face of it look
better than in other areas what do you
think that that is down to I mean is the
country simpler you better prepared than
others and is it likely to stay that way
I'm not so quite sure if you're really
well prepared if you're looking at the
shortage that we're facing for
protective gear masks gloves
disinfection disinfectants and it seems
that we're not really well prepared
however you look at the testing
capacities that we have in our country
and this is spread spread throughout the
country it's not only at one city these
are these are even available in smaller
cities shows that that we're better
prepared for the testing situation than
other countries nevertheless I think we
would be short of saying that we were
well-prepared there are some who are out
there who don't really believe that this
virus is that dangerous how do you see
society right now adapting to the
pandemic and you know the general
mindset of the public is very quickly we
had here some local elections just two
weeks ago here but very I was really
shocked how people were still gathering
in parts we have wonderful weather here
in Bavaria to understand that we like to
gather however nobody a lot of people
didn't understand the urgency and the
severity of the Kovach 19 crisis that
we're facing and now that we're at
lockdown people start to understand and
comprehend what's happening and things
are changing I see it in the grocery
stores people are keeping their distance
they have coffee etiquettes that they're
using they're coughing into their their
sleeves people washing their hands more
using disinfectants if they are
available so I think people are learning
along this
as well how about wearing face masks
because we have a city hair llena
the first German city to introduce the
mandatory wearing a face mask Simeon
initially we were all told that it
doesn't really make too much of a
difference the narrative seems to be
changing where do you weigh in here
well the narrative is very simple it's
just that one solution or one size fits
all all the measures that we take are
important meaning they're wearing masks
even if they are adjusted made of cloth
they might be helpful but they're not as
good as surgical masks of course you
know disinfectants for your hands or
washing your hands frequently keeping
your distance away from your fellow
citizens these are all measures that are
together very important not by a single
measure itself wouldn't change anything
that much but altogether this could be
very helpful professor Andrew Alma thank
you so much for your time well let's
take a look now at some other ways
coronavirus is affecting people around
the world Russia has reported its
biggest one-day rise in new cases some
500 bringing the country's total to more
than 2,300 authorities in Belgium have
confirmed the death of a 12 year old
girl infected with Cova 19 although
serious infections among the young
remain rare several countries have
reported exceptions and the world's
Health Organization is warning that even
though the focus is now on Europe and
the United States the corona virus
pandemic is still quote far from over in
Asia and the Pacific region
well Brazil has Latin America's highest
number of reported coronavirus cases
more than 4,500 but that has not stopped
the country's populous president JL
Boston Otto of downplaying the danger
posed by the pandemic brazil's health
minister has openly contradicted the
president saying that people need to
protect themselves through social
distancing now social media giants are
stepping into the fray they are removing
posts showing the president disregarding
public health advice
Brazil's far-right president Jeb Olson
ro likes to portray himself as a man of
the people but his closeness to the
people in these images has proved too
much for social media platforms Facebook
Instagram and
they've now removed this video
accusing Boston ro of putting lives at
risk
by ignoring official guidelines on
social distancing but bolson ro is
unrepentant this total isolation if it
goes on like this in the future we will
have a serious problem with the brutal
amount of unemployment it will take
years to resolve the president alleges
his aim is to protect the poor who were
suffering the most as jobs are destroyed
because of quarantine measures he says
people need to get back to work
but this dance has put him at odds
not just with official advice from
health professionals imploring people to
stay at home but also with the majority
of Brazil state governors are many local
politicians they're busy repurposing
venues such as the Samba drum in Rio
turning it into a shelter for the
homeless and vulnerable for the duration
of the pandemic bracing for the
onslaught everyone's appeal is stay at
home their home is this one it will be
these spaces that are being offered so
the ideal is that they stay here and do
not walk around the streets and be
exposed to such a lethal virus as a
number of infections and deaths
increases another big concern is how to
stop the virus spreading among the
city's favelas here there's often no
running water or electricity and people
are increasingly dependent on food
handouts well an estimated one-third of
the global population is living in a
coronavirus locked down with
restrictions of public life and a ban on
gatherings of people now this is post a
serious problem for protest movements
around the world from the Friday's for
future climate strikes to Hong Kong's
pro-democracy protests but organizers
they are experimenting with online
demonstrations trying to voice their
demands without gathering together my
colleague our reporter I mean as if he
has been following this
storia forests I mean it's good to see
you here in the studio for a change
yeah what is an online demonstration
what does it look like well I think
people are still experimenting with this
they don't really know I mean there's
always been some kind of online activism
but this is really forcing their cards
now and they want to find out what works
and what doesn't one good example was a
protest organized by Szabo Lucca that's
an organization here in Germany that's
fighting for asylum rights so they are
concerned about the concentrations of
people in camps like on Moria on lesbos
so they organized a kind of virtual
march through Berlin had various tactics
involved one of them you can see here
they had people send sound bites from
Moria camp and asking for solidarity
they also had people design banners
hanging about their windows within
Berlin and they had a kind of virtual
March like I said where they went to
different institutions in Berlin and had
targeted tweet campaigns or email
campaigns so basically they said okay
everybody now is going to tweet or email
or phone call the interior ministry in
Berlin so everybody did that and they
got trending I mean they used this
hashtag leave no one behind and it was
trending yeah and was the hashtag leave
no one behind
it was the demonstration successful yeah
that was the number one trending hashtag
in Germany it even beat out Cova 19
which was a big feat nowadays they had
6000 people participate at the height of
the live stream this is all live
streamed on YouTube but the question of
whether or not that's effective I posed
that question to one of the organizers
and here's what he had to say right now
we have to be creative we have to find
new ways I think the online
demonstration was for the first thing
that we actually tried and did was a
very good thing
and also I think for the future you can
use these online tools to react on
things very quickly because you can
mobilize a lot of people online in the
in a short time and you don't have to
organize anything for demonstrations and
like ask of nominees for permission for
the demonstrations so you can activate a
lot of people in a short time but I
would say
it's like a site tool of activism it's
not what we want to do in the future
but it's probably going to be a very
powerful um necessary to right now you
know there's been criticism already
today of the Prime Minister in Hungary
Viktor Orban who has been given the
right to govern by decree there's no way
for the public really at this point to
protest against it are there other
examples of governments taking advantage
of this crisis
to put limits on freedom of speech sure
there are I think we're gonna see more
and more of them as time goes on but
human rights activists have pointed out
two examples in Russia the government
put a ban on public gatherings the very
same day that President Putin approved a
measure that would allow him to stay in
office until 2036 so the timing there
was pretty obvious or suggestive anyway
and also in Iraq there's been a protest
movement going on since October and that
has come to a virtual standstill after
the government put a ban on protests
they're back in at the end of February
when they only had one case of
coronavirus confirmed now that tally has
risen in that country but the ban is
still effective and it's really shut
down the protest movement so I think
people are going to be asking will we
get our rights back once the lockdowns
yeah rights and become endangered
especially when people are living in
fear I mean SF is always tell me thank
you thanks Brandon